[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
laurent certains bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous des ppte et la
république en marge du val de marne
rapporteur général du budget à
l'assemblée nationale
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
l'interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représentée
par stéphane bern et bonjour stéphane
bonjour qui dirige le bureau parisien du
journal ouest france on va commencer
avec jean castex que vous avez
rencontrés hier soir ils recevaient les
parlementaires de la majorité à matignon
que vous êtes il dit d'abord c'est un
moment convivial de rencontre entre ce
nouveau premier ministre et l'ensemble
des parlementaires de la majorité qui
pour la très grande majorité d'entre eux
ne connaissaient pas le nouveau premier
ministre donc d'abord c'était faire
connaissance échanger et puis jean
calquer c'est quelqu'un que je ne
connaissais pas moi même et donc j'ai eu
l'occasion d'échanger quelques mots avec
lui jean castex a tout de suite mis
l'accent sur sa volonté de se rapprocher
des territoires et de bien comprendre
effectivement les problématiques locales
je crois que c'est aller retour
permanent entre la politique nationale
et les besoins territoriaux qui font la
spécificité des parlementaires sont au
coeur aussi des préoccupations du
premier ministre donc c'est un échange
qui a beaucoup tourné autour de cela et
j'ai observé le premier ministre se
renseigner et s'intéresser de très près
à département d'origine de tel député ou
de tel sénateur quels étaient les
problématiques particulières dans tel ou
tel territoire
on sent déjà qu'il a besoin de
cartographier l'ensemble des difficultés
de notre pays parce que les mois
prochain qui vont arriver vont être durs
et lui-même a besoin d'avoir une vision
dans son cas l'impression et le
personnel vous avez vous à fait unique
et quads étendue pressé c'est un homme
de conviction
c'est un homme déterminé vous l'avez
senti à l'aise dans la fonction à tout à
fait à l'aise
vous savez jean castex a une expérience
qui fait qu'il n'aura pas besoin d'une
semaine d'adaptation il est tout de
suite opérationnels et puis à nouveau
il a très clairement à exprimer ce qu'il
avait déjà dit les jours précédents nous
sommes en mission pour ces deux
prochaines années nous sommes en mission
pour reconstruire le pays
ses premiers mots ont tout de suite été
d'expliquer que la crise que nous vivons
nous sommes au coeur encore de cette
crise la crise sanitaire n'est pas
terminée et la crise
mick et sociale commence juste nous
sommes à un carrefour qu'il est très
difficile aujourd'hui d'appréhender donc
il nous faut être très concentré trouver
les bonnes mesures c'est pour ça que
nous allons reprendre très rapidement le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour être tout de suite opérationnel
c'est l'obsession du premier ministre je
crois qu'il a raison
passées les quelques heures de
commentaires sur le casting du
remaniement qui sont vos évidemment
normal mais vont rajouter il faut il
faut très rapidement se remettre sur le
seul souci qui doit être le nôtre
l'efficacité des mesures que nous
prenons sert laissant savoir les taris
la transition écologistes avaient à
l'esprit des députés la majorité il ya
des regrets par rapport aux dépôts
départ d'edouard philippe je suis en
train vous savez vous quand on est
parlementaire en nombre regarde pas dans
le rétroviseur on ne se demande pas si
c'est déjà passé ce n'est pas ici le
thème populaire les députés est ce que
vous regrettez son départ edouard
philippe a été et je crois que tout le
monde mais vraiment tout le monde
majorité comme opposition le reconnaît a
été un très grand premier ministre et
moi personnellement je suis extrêmement
fier d'avoir pu travailler à ses côtés
pour le gouvernement en l'accompagnant
comme membre de la majorité
il a été un très grand premier mini
c'est ce que voulait aujourd'hui je vais
va nous avons matignon c'est le choix du
président de la république là qu'est la
question n'est pas de savoir si c'était
mieux avec edouard philippe ou si ce
sera mieux avec jean castex seront deux
séquences différentes nécessairement
mais dans la continuité du mandat du
président de la république et de la
majorité c'est ça qui est important de
bien comprendre il ya évidemment une
continuité
il ya une continuité avec deux hommes
différents avec des personnalités
différentes et probablement des choix
différents mais ça et avait là encore
fini avec ben si le lit tu dresses que
vous avez une explication sur ce
changement de premier ministre qui n'en
est pas vraiment dans les lignes en
termes de personnalité et je pense
qu'ils sont assez différents le
gouvernement est différent lui-même vous
avez des personnalités fortes et
pertinentes qui sont rentrés au
gouvernement barbara pompili numéro
trois du gouvernement ministre de la
transition écologique est un signal très
fort pour une des priorités qui devront
être celle de notre mandat on est un
exemple parmis parmi d'autres nous
n'aurons pas les même 2 ans que les
trois ans que nous avons eues auparavant
d'abord parce que le contexte
international et national est
sensiblement différent ça ne vous aura
pas échappé
et puis parce que les hommes et les
femmes qui le composent ne sont
les mêmes avec les priorités seront
également distinctes mais ce qui compte
à nouveau ce n'est pas de comparer
edouard philippe et jean castex est ce
que c'était mieux s qu'il était plus
comme ça est ce qu il était plus comme
si la seule chose qui compte c est ce
que le gouvernement castex est capable
avec sa majorité de répondre de façon
satisfaisante à la crise qui fait face à
notre pays c'est la seule priorité et
c'est la seule boussole qui doit nous
guider
c'est la seule priorité la seule
boussole ya quand même une question
c'est-à-dire nommer un premier ministre
qui vient les républicains qui est
réputé sarkozyste qui se définit comme
gaulliste social est ce que ça va pas
créer de nouvelles déceptions au sein de
votre majorité ou autrement dit ceux qui
espéraient encore un virage un coup de
barre à gauche ou verts l'écologie ce
qu'il peut pas y avoir de nouveau déçu
et la création ou de nouveaux départs en
la création d'un quatrième groupe
décidant à l'assemblée est ce que ça
c'est envisageable ou si c'est
difficilement c'est quelque chose qui
est définie définitivement passé et je
note depuis hier soir effectivement que
beaucoup de commentaires se font sur les
commentaires c'est une question font sur
une partie effectivement de l'échiquier
classique politique parce que le premier
ministre est issu effectivement de la
droite un peu et il le reconnaît très
volontiers et encore heureux il n'y a
aucune difficulté là dessus nous avons
dépasser ces clivages pour rassembler
autour du président de la république
mini jeu mais on est issu leurs anciens
chargés de l'économie et vous le dites
ça va être une partie importante de la
seconde partie du quinquennat on est
issu vous devriez donc aussi parlé de
jean yves le drian numéro deux du
gouvernement issu de la gauche vous
devriez aussi parlé de barbara pompili
de brigitte bourguignon de marlène
schiappa et j'en passe au final si vous
prenez les ministres de plein exercice
vous savez quoi si vous êtes une
personnalité qui soit c'est à la
république aux marchands de me demandais
m'étais fait une promesse et de ne plus
parler de clivage droite gauche mais je
vais faire une exception pour vous si
vous voulez faire de la comptabilité
droite gauche regardez les ministres de
plein exercice y en a plus qui viennent
de la gauche qui viennent de la droite
donc vous voyez tout ça n'a pas beaucoup
comarch
réalisée ils ont changé d'étiquette à 17
exactement
donc nous avons dépassé qui vache n'est
pas pour les recréer en 2020 jean castex
n'est plus et l'ère jean castex et chef
de la majorité présidentielle avec des
ministres composé anciennement de gens
issus de la droite
anciennement issu de la gauche et
surtout aussi des gens issus de la
société civile a été le parti cdu pour
mort et qui par exemple qui me
semble-t-il n'était affilié à aucun
parti
avant même s'il avait lui-même sa propre
sensibilité donc vous voyez bien que
nous poursuivons la logique et la
dynamique qui a toujours été la nôtre
celle de rassembler autour d'un projet
pour la france est d'unir toutes les
forces et toutes les bonnes volontés
progressistes pour trouver des solutions
faciles les étiquettes les étiquettes a
dit que ça sera jamais notre priorité de
questions sur l'étiquette leadership n'a
jamais adhéré à la république en marche
est ce que jean castex vous a dit qu'il
avait le faire mais écoutez ça peu me
chaut
franchement vous dit il de la majorité
un peu me chaut le pays va traverser une
crise sans précédent on craint on craint
des centaines de milliers d'emplois
perdus
est ce que notre priorité c'est
franchement de savoir si notre premier
ministre va adhérer à la manière dont ça
fait travailler avec les perles préfère
de la majorité qui stéphane le rappeler
moi je vais vous dire une chose très
simple jean castex est à partir de la
semaine dernière le chef de la majorité
point à la ligne à partir du moment où
on est chef de la majorité on n'est pas
en dehors on n'est pas à côté on n'est
pas dans un parti satellite en et chef
de la majorité et de plain-pied dans la
majorité et l'ensemble des ministres du
gouvernement l'ensemble des mines et du
gouvernement font partie de la majorité
présidentielle de la même manière que
l'ensemble des députés des groupes de la
majorité le son vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure de l'est des personnalités
issues de la société civile le président
la république lui-même la semaine
dernière par les deux nouveaux visages
de nouveaux talents eu 31 noms dévoilés
hier soir
et sur ces 31 n'y a que trois personnes
qui sont issus de la société civile
c'est là il n'y a pas une déception un
peu c'est un peu ce que c'est c'est un
peu simple rac par rapport à l'ensemble
c'est pas vrai nous respectons tout à
fait le même équilibre il y avait quand
même il ya quand même que trois
personnalités issues de la société il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui étaient issus
de la société civile dans le
gouvernement précédent qui sont restés
au gouvernement
marlène schiappa par exemple en ayant un
très bel exemple
ce gouvernement si vous le regardez à la
loupe il est plutôt bien équilibré c'est
ce que nous voulons toujours conservé
cette société civile à vient apporter
son expérience du terrain de métier qui
peut dire que monsieur dupont moretti ne
connaît pas le quotidien des
juridictions il va pouvoir apporter à la
chancellerie comme garde des sceaux son
expérience métier son expérience de
terrain
ce ne sera pas une mission aisée il le
sait il a beaucoup de travail devant lui
par rapport à cela pour mener des
réformes maintenant qu'il est déjà édité
ici là vous entendez enregistrés par les
déclarations guerre la société civile
est toujours au coeur du gouvernement
elle est aussi surtout au coeur de la
majorité parlementaire
faut-il rappeler quand même que la quasi
totalité des députés issus du groupe la
république en marche n'était pas députés
avant avait un métier moi même le
premier et retrouveront un métier un
jour nous avons fait ce choix ce pari
que la politique n'était pas une
carrière mais une mission à laquelle
nous devions répondre justement face à
des défis tels que nous les vivons
aujourd'hui c'est à dire une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent
je n'ai moi qu'une seule priorité quand
je me lève le matin c'est savoir si on
va trouver des solutions efficaces je me
fiche de savoir si je viens de la
société civile si j'étais au ps ou à
l'air avant je me demande si je suis
efficace et utile
allez sur sur le fond de la politique on
va venir au budget mais sur ce que vous
a dit jean castex hier vous avez dit
vous a beaucoup parlé des territoires
est ce que vous pensez la fracture
territoriale c'était une des priorités
des manuels mâcon en 2017 résorber cette
fracture territoriale pour le moment il
a échoué
est ce que jean castex peut contribuer à
la résorber cette fracture
jean castex fait partie de ces
personnages d'état qui connaissent bien
le terrain puisqu'il est lui-même élu
local en tant que maire de prades donc
cette double casquette est extrêmement
utile et puis surtout jean castex il
aime les territoires profondément ça il
faut pas il faut pas essayé d'aimer les
territoires il faut les aimer
profondément il faut les connaître et
jean castex a ce talent il a cette
chance là pour le gouvernement
donc oui elle territoire seront
systématiquement une priorité dans
toutes les politiques publiques qui
seront menées il ya plusieurs manières
de penser les territoires qui assoient
se demander si ce qui est voté à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
s'applique bien dans l'ensemble des
territoires
il ya aussi des manières plus agiles
améliorons l'expérimentation dans les
territoires par exemple allons plus loin
dans la différenciation entre les
territoires donnant peut-être plus
d'autonomie aux territoires
si demain une loi venait par exemple à
être votée au parlement la compétence
pour les collectivités en tout cas il
faut remettre tout ça sur la table et je
sais que jean castex qui est
parfaitement disposé ce qui est sûr
c'est que nous échouerons collectivement
si nous mettons pas ensemble état
collectivités territoriales ensemble
avec le même objectif c'est répondre à
la crise
et c'est sauver l'emploi dans notre pays
tout en accompagnant notre société vers
une transition écologique plus
ambitieuse plus perdu sur cette question
des territoires est qu'ils n'ont pas
nous avons brisé au début du quinquennat
vont travailler avec les collectivités
territoriales de façon permanente nous
n'avons pas créé le ministère de la
cohésion des territoires
hier jacqueline gourault qui est déjà là
avec avec sébastien lecornu ils ont fait
un travail considérable
les discussions avec régions de france
avec l'association des départements de
france avec les associations du bloc
communal ont été permanentes pendant ces
trois dernières années mais là nous
sommes face à un nouveau défi
ce nouveau défi c'est sauver l'emploi et
c'est accélérer la transition écologique
ce double objectif on ne le fera pas
depuis paris voilà on ne le fera pas
depuis paris il naîtra des territoires
paris en effet la loi les parlements ils
sont présents mais on ne le fera que en
bonne intelligence avec les besoins du
territoire et les remontées du
territoire et vous savez c c'est notre
adn depuis le début de faire remonter
les besoins territoriaux
il est vrai qu'avec jean castex nous
allons le mettre en oeuvre aussi de
façon tout à fait appliquer dès la
construction de la loi et des les
propositions gouvernementales
alors commençons par mettre en place une
nouvelle conférence nationale des
territoires où on la relance en est ce
que vous savez quand est-ce qu'elle sera
programmé cette nouvelle que 200 est en
fait le gouvernement mettra une feuille
de route très rapidement sur la table ce
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui
d'abord nous allons reprendre nos
travaux parlement si vous me le
permettez nous avons une conférence des
présidents à 10 heures autour du
président ferrand pour que justement le
ministre relations parlement présente
nouvel ordre du jour qui est proposé aux
parlementaires la question est que jean
castex est exprimé sur un stand de
choses notamment par exemple en disant
qu'il voulait que le ségur de la santé
bouclé cette semaine donc on sent qu'il
ya une envie d'aller très vite sur le
ségur le jeu fait le ségur cette semaine
ça ça vous paraît raisonnable c'est
possible jean castex a raison d'être
ambitieux dans le calendrier puisque
nous savons bien que choisit la fin du
mandat
elle n'est pas en mai 2022 elle est
avant elle est au moins six mois avant
puisqu'après derrière l'actualité 6 les
campagnes et les campagnes prennent
malheureusement trop vite le dessus mais
c'est un regret je pense que nous
devrions être capables de mener
politiques publiques jusqu'au bout mais
dans les faits les six derniers mois
sont consacrés aux affaires courantes
tant que nous avons nous avons 18 mois
nous avons 18 mois devant nous pour
appliquer ça ne suffit pas de voter il
faut appliquer donc concerté voter la
loi appliquée c'est long et c'est normal
que ce soit long parce qu'il faut
prendre le temps de s'assurer que ce que
nous votons et bien adéquation avec les
besoins des territoires confère ce que
je disais plus tôt et nous devons nous
assurer que ce gain appliquez vous
attendez à ce qu'elle retombe dessus
gilson saldivar relancer dès cet été
oui il faut aller vite pour pouvoir
avoir une vision d'ensemble de la
rentrée et cette feuille de route à la
rentrée elle doit être appliquée avec un
rythme qui est soutenu pour que nous
puissions être assurée qu'elle soit
appliquée avant la fin de notre
quinquennat je crois que là-dessus que
nous devons être un pack devrait être un
maul mobilisés avec la même feuille de
route et à partir moment elle est
choisie qu'elle ait décidé qu'elle est
acceptée il n'y a qu'une seule priorité
celles appliquées autre sujet c'est la
réforme des retraites jean castex dit
vouloir recevoir les partenaires sociaux
très vite dès cette semaine
est ce que cette réforme des retraites
il faut la remettre sur la table je
ferais la même réponse que pour le sujet
du ségur de la santé la réforme des
retraites n'est pas devenue caduque dans
son principe
avec la crise du coc u19 je dirais même
plus l'aggravation de certaines
inégalités sociales l'a rendu encore
plus nécessaire et des déficits du
régime de retraite les fameuses première
et seconde ligne qu'on attend ça lui
étant applaudi tous les soirs sont ceux
qui vont souffrir des inégalités de
pensions qui vont se créer si nous
modifions pas le système
si nous ne faisons pas ces systèmes
universels de retraite par points nous
devons aller au bout pour ces
personnes-là
nous devons aller au bout de la promesse
que nous avons faite aux français en
c'est de relancer cette réforme fait
chasser vivante laurent samama électives
en deçà de ce qui est et qui vend c'est
parfois l'incompréhension dans le débat
à mener de front une volonté de modifier
le système universel de retraite
c'est-à-dire en faire vraiment le même
système pour tous dans sa mécanique
et puis ce qu'on a appelé la réforme
paramétrique
c'est à dire son financement et s'assure
effectivement que nous puissions là
l'équilibré le plus tôt possible
ces deux combats de front qui ont pu
parfois mener une confusion est donc un
clivage que que vous citez la partie
systémique de la réforme plus de justice
sociale
à la clé elle est voulue par la plupart
de nos concitoyens
elle veut notamment voulu par un certain
nombre de partenaires sociaux à
commencer par la cfdt
donc il nous faut aller au bout de cette
réforme allait elle est souhaitée elle
est voulue mais les cibles étaient
possibles vous le savez très bien
laurent certains il était possible parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de déséquilibre du
régime
mais là c'est pas le cas est ce que
cette réforme systémique elle est encore
possible sans toucher aux paramètres
salle et le rapporteur général du budget
que je suis vous dire que les déficits
publics que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
vont durer quelques années
attendre la fin des déficits publics de
notre pays pour commencer à réformer
serait coupable
pourquoi parce que il nous faudrait
attendre de longues années de longues
années pour pouvoir redémarrer des
réformes qui sont non seulement
nécessaires pour notre pays qui seront
elles mêmes la condition des excédents
primaires demain si vous me passez
l'expression technique c'est-à-dire
cette capacité à vous rendre monde non
seulement plus juste mais surtout plus
équilibrée financièrement parce que
l'équilibré financier c'est pas un
plaisir de technocrates vous savez
l'équilibré financier c'est juste
assurer aux générations d'après un
système qui marche ni plus ni moins
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas la crise
du coville 19 à aggraver les comptes
publics et c'est normal nous devions
nous endetter pour sauver nos emplois
mais demain nous devront résorber ses
déficits
en attendant il est nécessaire de mener
ces réformes de structure il est
nécessaire à double titre parce qu'elles
sont source de plus de justice sociale
et à sorte source de plus de lisibilité
n'oubliez pas que l'ensemble des
concitoyens l'ensemble de ce qui nous
regarde ne connaissent toujours pas avec
précision comment fonctionnent leurs
systèmes de retraites
et quelle sera leur pension à la fin de
leur cas
je crois qu'il est temps effectivement
de mettre un terme à tout ça est ce que
les choses ont plus de chances d'aboutir
du fait même de la personnalité de jean
castex qui est peut-être plus souple sur
les questions budgétaires ou moins
arquebouté ou moins crispé que ne
l'était edouard philippe sur les
questions paramètres de demain
deux-tiers de regarder me garderai bien
de toute comparaison sur les
personnalités entre edouard philippe
et vous parlez de 4 en début d'interview
c'est là aussi que le souci des finances
publiques n'est pas mis à la poubelle
avec jean castex et là encore c'est le
rapporteur du budget qui vous le dit
mais il sera plus souple dans les
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux que ne l'était edouard philippe
sur ces questions précises les finances
publiques ne sont pas une option
ni un plaisir sadique de quelques
technocrates de bercy
les finances publiques sont la condition
d'un système qui perdure dans notre pays
notre protection sociale dépend aussi
son équilibre financier les français le
savent les français sont pas idiots ils
ont des budgets à gérer chez eux ils
savent très bien que si nous on
équilibre on pas les comptes à terme
nous n'y arriverons pas en revanche ce
qui est vrai vous avez raison c'est que
nous n'allons pas demander un équilibre
des comptes sociaux ou des comptes de
l'état dans les deux ans qui viennent
ça n'aurait nul sens puisque la crise
nous a amené les du comment à nous
endetter de façon massive pour répondre
justement aux besoins des entreprises
des salariés des ménages les plus
fragiles des collectivités territoriales
donc évidemment que ça ne se fera pas en
deux ans mais la trajectoire de
rééquilibrer nos comptes publics à terme
restera évidemment une priorité du
gouvernement de jean castex
comme le précédent comme n'importe quel
gouvernement responsable fils qu'on
parle des comptes publics dernière
question sur le budget vous le disiez à
l'examen du projet de loi finances
rectificatif 3 était interrompue pour
cause de remaniement il va y ait une
conférence des présidents il va
reprendre quand alors je souhaite qu'il
reprenne dès demain puisque l'urgence
économique et social elle n'attend pas
donc nous pouvons nous permettre de le
décaler de vendredi dernier à mercredi
ça ne va pas changer grand chose à la
promulgation mais guère plus donc il
nous reste mille trente amendements à
débattre à l'assemblée nationale en
première lecture donc voyez encore
beaucoup de travail donc je souhaite
effectivement que nous puissions
reprendre dès demain après midi pour
finir ça sur la semaine que le sénat
puisse commencer en commission des
finances la semaine suivante voir cette
fin de semaine s'il le souhaite
et que nous puissions retrouver un
rythme tel que tel que prévu pour que la
promulgation et bien lieu fin du mois
début août c'est à dire une mise en
application rapide pendant l'été parce
que je vous rappelle que ce plfr c'est
le secteur hôtellerie le secteur
restauration le café tout le tourisme
les médias et un certain nombre de
secteurs prioritaires comme l'automobile
qui sont adressés et qui vont être
aidées en priorité donc ceci les
salariés n'attendent pas justement
quelques signaux pouvoir être quatrième
budget rectificatif ou après ce sera
directement le projet de la finance
c'est trop tôt pour le dire c'est au
gouvernement de le décider nous verrons
bien à quel sera leur choix
moi je crois que si nous faisons un gros
projet de loi de finances rectificative
l'a bien complet pendant le mois de
juillet ne sera peut-être pas nécessaire
d'en refaire un d
dès la rentrée mais c'est au
gouvernement de le décider nous verrons
bien ce qu'elle sera ses priorités vous
savez parfois un projet de l'audience
rectificative est nécessaire pour
quelques mesures nouvelles qui sont
annoncés pendant l'été donc rien n'était
exclu à ce stade et puis vous savez en
temps de crise ne faut jamais rien
exclure et savoir être souple et agile
et réactif emmanuel macron est proposé à
edouard philippe
la tâche de construire mission pour
consolider la majorité en vue des
prochaines élections ils allaient
refuser si j'ai bien compris pourquoi ce
qu'il a refusé puis deuxième question
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de de
proposer cette mission à edouard
philippe cc c'est pas le job du délégué
général de la république en marche
stanislas guérissa 2 de consolider
l'image de la majorité
alors d'abord je dois pas avoir les
mêmes sources que vous parce que je n'ai
pas entendu et or philippe refusé
edouard philippe sera à plaire et d'or
philippe sera un pilier de la majorité
présidentielle à dire oui ou encore
présidentielle jean philippe vient
d'être élu maire du havre
si vous voulez bien les cellules un
petit peu à reprendre ses fonctions
respirer un petit peu et vous lui
poserez la question dans quelques
semaines mais il n'y a aucun doute que
dans philippe fera partie de notre
projet pour l'année 2011 mais sur cette
mission c'est paris c'est pas les gens
de stanislas guérini ces deux contrées
décennies le délégué général de la
république en marche il fait un
excellent travail tout comme le modem et
nos partenaires des radicaux et d'agir
font aussi ce travail de consolidation
de la majorité et de philippe est une
personnalité reconnue qui a conduit le
gouvernement pendant trois ans nous
user de ses compétences pour les
prochains mois les prochaines années
préparer l'avenir c'est une évidence
lui-même le sait et je suis sûr que nous
travaillerons très bien ensemble à
l'avenir en tout cas je le souhaite
parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect
d'admiration pour lui et merci beaucoup
merci à vincent martin d'avoir été avec
nous merci stéphane demain votre place
ce sera bruno retailleau le président du
groupe l'est républicain ici au sénat on
passe sous tito club des territoires